they're taking my family off one by one
let's fight like demons what up friends
we finally got
a trailer for dune so we're gonna talk
about everything we learned about the
film
including that giant sand worm right now
on the ketchup
the first trailer for denis villeneuve's
highly anticipated adaptation of frank
herbert's 1965 novel has a lot of what
fans were hoping to see
a better look at some of the characters
the vast desert landscapes of dune
and of course the real star of the film
the giant sand worms
i am already living for all the 20 20
memes that this thing is giving us
the sand worms which are attracted to
vibrations on the surface and are
ultimately what produced the spice on
the planet of arrakis
aka dune are seen a couple of times once
swallowing up some equipment on the
surface
and later coming face to face with
timothy chalamet's character
paul lato of course anything that comes
face to face with timothy chalamet i am
incredibly jealous of
speaking of chalamet we got plenty of
shots of his central character paul lato
doing things like kissing battling
walking standing and dropping one of
dune's most famous quotes
fierce the mind killer and the person
that he's kissing is zendaya's blue eyed
spice addicted shaney
a warrior in a tribe called the fremen
who live on arrakis
now we see her wearing white in what is
most likely one of paul's dream
sequences and also in her still suit
which is a specialized suit that
preserves and recycles all of the body's
liquid waste to survive
the desert i could have totally used one
of those here in la last weekend
we also got plenty of action from jason
momoa's duncan idaho a swordmaster for
oscar isaac's duke lado who helps train
paul in the art of war
by the way his reunion with paul has got
a lot of people on social media
smoothing including moi
then there's dave bautista's the beast
character an eerie and brooding soldier
leading the ground forces of the villain
baron harkonnen
played by stellen skarsgard the giant
war sequences seen in the trailer are
between his forces and duke lados but
the beast isn't the only odd looking
thing we saw in the trailer though
because now that i know what an
ornithopter looks like
a transport vehicle with wings that flap
like an insect my life will never be the
same
all of civilization depends on it and
based on the mostly positive response on
social media fans are
digging the visuals velanov has given
this story doing it with crisp
cinematography that captures the dark
dusty and desolate feel of the deserts
in jordan where much of the film was
shot
but it is worth noting that many are
critical of the fact that the film does
not feature
any arab or islamic representation
despite the fact that a lot of the
characters language
social theory and religious imagery were
borrowed from their culture
perhaps that can be corrected in future
films or the spin-off series that's
coming to hbo max
the future i can see it
all right friends time to kick it over
to you now did this trailer get you
excited for dune i know it did because
so many of you guys in the comments ask
for a ketchup episode breakdown of this
trailer so let us know your thoughts and
feelings
also if you want more movie and
streaming news head on over to
rottentomatoes.com
and please join our fan group on
facebook it's like a hit of the spice
but you know without the creepy blue
eyes and if you don't want to miss out
on any future episodes of this
show be sure to hit that subscribe
button and notification bell and as
always we cannot thank you enough for
watching the ketchup my name's not perez
and i need to go buy me a still suit
because it is hot here in l.a
bye
[Music]
you